estime aussi que les russes sont
peut-être plus en difficulté qui
n'aurait envisagé au départ selon le new
york times les russes auraient même
réclamé à pékin une aide économique et
militaire ces dernières heures ce à quoi
a réagi la chine 1 ce matin en colère
sans démentir pour pour autant même si
c'est un peu l'idée la chine qui accuse
l'amérique de désinformation je propose
d'écouter la partie chinoise et pioneer
vient juste après
les états unis ont récemment diffusé une
série de fausses nouvelles visant la
chine sur la question de l'ukraine avec
des intentions malveillantes la position
de la chine sur la question de l'ukraine
a été claire et cohérente roumanie nous
avons toujours joué un rôle constructif
en appelant à la paix et aux
négociations la question la plus urgente
à l'heure actuelle est que toutes les
parties fassent preuve de retenue
refroidissant la situation tendue au
lieu de jeter de l'huile sur le feu et
favorise une résolution diplomatique au
lieu d'aggraver la situation suis-je
dit voilà pas vraiment ravi l'allier
chinois à baptiste il vient de dire la
position de la chine depuis le début de
cette guerre a été claire et cohérente
pas vraiment finalement non pas alors
pas du tout va en tout cas une grande
prudence là il est en train de réagir à
ces déclarations américaines en fait
selon lesquelles alors ce sont des
fuites de presse mais selon lesquelles
la russie se seraient tournés vers la
chine pour demander une aide militaire
une aide économique également la chine
donc nie en bloc et effectivement c'est
intéressant d'abord je vous propose
juste de se positionner du côté
américain il faut savoir que ces
déclarations américaines si elles sont
confirmées elles interviennent quelques
heures avant il rencontre au sommet au
tout à l'heure à rome entre jake
sullivan vous conseiller à la sécurité
nationale et yange essieux le plus haut
diplomate chinois il va être clairement
question d'ukraine il s'agit peut-être
d'une pression faite côté américain pour
que la chine est bien dévoile un peu
plus son jeu justement il rappelait
également à la chine qu'elle n'est pas à
l'abri de sanctions aussi si elle
soutient la russie alors on va revenir
sur la position chinoise effectivement
elle peut s'apparenter à ce que un
universitaire et un universitaire
américain pardon a appelé une
khalid est pro-russe c'est assez
intéressant concrètement la chine
n'approuve pas la position russe son
offensive en ukraine mais elle ne la
condamne pas elle s'est abstenue par
exemple à plusieurs reprises à l'onu
lors de résolution qui condamne et
justement l'agression russe on notera
également que chez jean ping le
président chinois a appelé vladimir
poutine à aucun moment il n'a décroché
son téléphone pour voler d'immigrés
lenski depuis le début du conflit et la
plupart du temps les médias chinois
reprennent des éléments de langage de la
russie il n'y a pas de guerre il s'agit
d'un conflit d'une opération spéciale de
tension donc la chine c'est un allié de
circonstance de la russie elle veut le
rester ne lâchera pas la russie en rase
campagne mais elle ne veut pas non plus
passer pour un paria au vis-à-vis des
occidentaux et elle ne veut pas
s'infliger des sanctions occidentales si
son soutien à la russie est trop fort
donc pour des raisons économiques elle
ne veut pas elle ne veut pas avoir les
occidentaux contre elle pour des raisons
idéologiques elle ne veut pas que ce
conflit devienne une espèce de guerre
deux blocs avec d'un côté des valeurs
occidentales défendu par l'europe et les
états unis contre les régimes
autoritaires la russie est donc
forcément la chine qui sera impliqué
dans ce bloc des régimes autoritaires
voilà c'est un peu compliqué mais tout
ça explique effectivement cette retenue
de la position chinoise qui ne veut pas
jouer un rôle de médiateur depuis le
début dans ce conflit alors que certains
pays l'ont appelée justement à prendre
le téléphone appeler poutine appelé
zelensky étendait de jouer lé rôle
d'intermédiaire voilà sa volonté de
rester à distance mais elle est
finalement rattrapé cette chine on
suivra évidemment attentivement l'issue
de ces échanges avec les américains
aujourd'hui merci beaucoup
batista l'aurait